does your
wife see you guys as equals no not at
all not even from day one not even from
when we were
we were dating she expected me to be the
man
right i told this story before it's like
when we were when we were dating um i
had my truck and she had her car and
whenever we were
uh going on a date or we were going
somewhere and we were driving her car
she would hand me the keys
so you're driving and that was i sort of
have used that i've
used that illustration a lot but uh that
was
my first indication that she wanted
somebody who was in control who was
going to drive the family was going to
drive
the the marriage right she expected that
she had she comes from a you know
fairly traditional family her father uh
my my father-in-law who i get along with
great
now i get along great uh very much an
alpha male very much the guy that was
sort of the patriarch of the family
still is to this day
and um she expected me to at least in
some way be
the patriarch be the guy who is the and
i hate to use that term now because it
means something else
to you know try ons but uh but that's
you know in a nutshell that's what it is
she expected me to drive the car she
expected me to drive the relationship
and the marriage and to be in control of
it
and to be the focus in the direction of
it uh another example i use is that when
i decided to take a job
at a particular liquor company that
wanted to relocate to orlando i didn't
i sat her down at a you know we went out
and had sushi one night and i said you
know we're gonna move to orlando because
there's this great job for me and
we're gonna relocate and i didn't the
her response wasn't well what about my
friends what about my family what about
my career here what about this here what
about that here
wasn't that the first thing out of her
mouth was you're my husband i go where
you go
where where when are we leaving you know
where do i need this kind of thing
right and and so i think a lot of people
get like kind of freaked out about that
and i think
like if you if you were to ask like
certain guys about that
they would say well oh how did you do
that it's like i didn't do that that's
just
how our relationships work right that's
that's just how we are
i i'm i'm the one who is the have
headship of this family
you ask women if you ask feminists if
you ask even not even women who
claim not to be feminists they'll be
like oh you must have her really on a
tight leash
right or you must really have her under
your thumb i'm like
no i don't have her under my thumb she's
where she wants to be this is what this
is how we do it
and and with this is how we've always
done it so uh and i'm looking at that i
see the chat there
i'll talk about dread game here in just
a little bit but um i don't
i i know this topic will come up so i'm
just gonna say it right now i don't game
my wife
uh and i and you know of course the the
thumbnail there was a little bit of
a clickbait i guess but i don't game my
wife it's well i don't have to game my
wife
because this is just how we are this is
just how i am
and my default is to whatever is sort of
the red pill default when it comes to
you know any kind of
uh decision making that happens in the
family um
said this also is that i think i can
count on the fingers of one hand how
many times we've ever
had a real fight and any of those fights
have never lasted more than 24 hours
you